good morning everybody I'm super excited
I just got a shower happy Monday ah it's
time for gratitude journal number 16 the
live stream uh for those you who are new
every day we talk about three things
that we're grateful for i will share
mine i want you guys to share yours in
the live chat leave in the comments
below it's really important as
entrepreneurs that we're grateful for
what we have it makes us happy
entrepreneurs it makes us healthier
entrepreneurs and it's important that we
do it consistently just like motivation
you can be motivated one day and then
wake up the next day and it's gone you
got to do gratitude every single day if
you want to reap the benefits of it and
the other really important part is that
you have to feel it it's got to be
important it's got to be something that
you take a few seconds to actually feel
here if you wanted to feel your soul and
you want to get the benefits of
gratitude it's not just listing some
things off it is actually feeling it
while you're talking about it so I'm
going to share three things you guys
watching live put it in the chat what
you're grateful for three things and
those you watching afterwards leave it
in the comments do it consistently
whether you're with me daily or you're
doing on your own doing consistently you
do it for you do it for a week you do it
for a month you don't for three months
you keep going I promise you you're
going to feel the benefits of it so
today what I am grateful for number one
is my audio book I'm recording the audio
book today i have three days of
recording my audio book i'm so pumped
for your one word there it is as a
result after there's no live stream
after this is no legal legends live
stream because i have to leave after
this is done in eight minutes i'm i'm
getting on the Vesta and going to the
other side of town to start recording
I've got three days of audio recording
on three Mondays and so from ten a.m. to
five PM straight audio recording
bringing fire so I'm super super super
excited I'm a little nervous which is
good
super grateful for the opportunity may
be channeling you guys I'm in the studio
recording um number two for me I'm
really grateful for you guys right
believe nation the audience because none
of this is possible right I wouldn't
have a book deal I wouldn't be going
downtown to to record the audio book
nobody would be watching this live
stream when we will have the impact and
so super grateful for all you guys
watching the videos commenting filling
me up the comments that you guys leave
is my fuel is what gets me jacked up and
excited every day knowing that the work
that I'm creating is having an impact so
thank you guys so much I'm constantly
grateful for for all of you and
especially today and number three number
three I'm grateful for the Blue Jays
making the playoffs it was a tense
weekend a number of games that happened
and we ended up barely making it into
the playoffs and getting the top
wild-card spot so super excited about
that Tuesday night is going to be the
wild card game one game decides who
stays in and who goes on and so my
tuesdays booked off hopefully you guys
will watch the Blue Jays as well cheer
them on to victory so those are my three
things I'm grateful for the audio blog
I'm grateful for you guys bleep nation
and grateful for the Blue Jays make it
into the playoffs time to do some shout
outs and over to you about what you're
grateful for we got six minutes so let's
see what's up Jay rise first up in the
chat thankful for easy energized
mornings for chefs who provide delicious
meals for muscles which help us move
through life for maintenance people
janitors garbageman etc who keep things
running I love a man how often do
recognize the meetings people in our
lives I love it millville I got it right
millville grateful for my family friends
and my pets grateful for a very
productive morning I love
what else bunch of chat about your
chatter sky's the limit oh nine I like
that I like that name good morning
everyone welcome zeno here we are I'm
before number one my energy while not
having had a lot of sleep number to my
calf body part of the day my calf being
ok now after cramping up during
Saturday's basketball game it still hurt
yesterday but it doesn't anymore I love
it and number three scream for ice cream
yummy I kind of want a peanut Buster
parfait no dairy queen peanut Buster
parfait mmm thinking about ice cream you
made me think about ice cream housing
them in sherry good morning good morning
cheri g rise grateful to use my phone as
a portable Wi-Fi hotspot love it Anthony
hola youtube what's up Anthony welcome
aboard Stephanie have you read the book
magic the secret I have not read the
book magic the secret I don't know what
it's about but thank you for the
recommendation Chandi I'm grateful for
my pillow I'm good for my pillow to it I
have a harder time sticker when i get to
hotels i'm not used to my pillow hugs me
when I'm low puts me to sleep when I'm
Restless sees me cry and relaxes my
shrieks gives me support when my
troubled back when my trouble back
troubles me your villa pillow I love it
Rashid hello what's up Rashid sky's the
limit three things I'm grateful for
imagination creative solutions and
health I love that Anthony is grateful
for awesome clients number one I guess
it's more coming lower what else archive
hell off from France welcome aboard our
kind Cherie Griffin for being here it's
my boost to work on my biz I love it ten
minutes every day in the morning at
least weekdays in the morning I had to
make time for this for you guys i cancel
my other
stream like I got to get downtown so the
other side of telling about at in three
minutes shut this off and run to get to
my best spot and drive because it's
important because this is important
because doing gratitude daily is
important Nicholas scruple for Evans
videos love that Nicholas welcome aboard
what else what else what else much
welcome aboard even her chocolate for
breakfast pillows are awesome especially
my hashtag fantasy pillow I love that
Blair BMB I'm grateful to wake up every
morning have these videos i love that
hey I'm grateful to wake up and have you
guys here every day klb and i'm grateful
for my concrete house because it's
keeping me dry during this intense
weather in hurricane matthew stay safe k
ow we're thinking of you man stay safe
Kelly morning everyone I'm grateful for
books can't believe I never used to read
much also people for garbage day and
oversized garbage bags a lot of a lot of
shadow 2 garbage day garbage man and
women I love it being organized feels
good manoj hi welcome aboard my
knowledge Sherri's grateful for the five
senses so I can smell taste feel here
and touch I love that utiful moisture
grateful for hope Zeno I'm grateful for
being able to watch us in Amsterdam
while you're talking to a camera in
Toronto I love a man power of the
Internet bringing people together
bringing believe nation cannot be
contained within one country I love it
Anthony okay the rest of the three from
Anthony number why grateful for my
amazing clients number two Griffin for
having a job I'm so passionate about and
I can and I can help people change their
lives I love that man super important
and number three grateful for Evan
growing a full beard he promised me ages
ago Nina's not a fan Nina's not a fan so
this is maybe as long as it gets and
it's gonna have to it's gonna come off
what else Oh
and the scrolling on this is crazy every
time it happens at least once here we go
okay que el bien I'm grateful for Evan
Carmichael absolutely love this channel
everything you're doing boss I
appreciate that thank you for the love
Jude hey when I decided to take a year
off and rediscover myself please give me
some advice normally we do advise in the
last room afterwards come back tomorrow
at nine ten we'll do the live stream and
league today is all about gratitude
cherry cream for the love here I agree
and nessie I'm truly people for you Evan
I'm grateful for God's vision and
purpose for my life great for my
children love that Nessie thank you for
sharing 9-10 guys I gotta run I love you
guys have an amazing day have an amazing
start to the week go and do something
impactful in your business and in your
life today show some gratitude and love
for those are watching afterwards make
sure to leave it down in the comments 3
things you are grateful for continued to
believe guys or whatever your one word
is and I'll see you soon